16 seconds remaining and deciding not to
call a timeout
holiday spin move gets inside lands goes
that's good
and the bucks go up by one with 11.4
remaining
holidays struggling all night long
offensively
with one of the biggest buckets for the
bucks
drew holiday puts milwaukee up it's nets
ball when we come back
brooklyn obviously has to shoot quickly
why would you even have any defender
inside the three-point mark you
shouldn't be defending anybody
inside out to durant durant one dribble
fires it up oh back of the rim
jubilation here in milwaukee the bucks
are right back in the series
they did a great job mike down 83.80
after the durant three
6-0 to finish the game and what a great
performance of chris middleton the
all-star
who's been so wonderful for this team
35 points 15 rebounds couple of clutch
free throws
and a big bounce back game here's that
possession jeff
[Applause]
well defended i thought pj tucker was
going to try to take the foul
[Applause]
if you're the bucks you got to be
thrilled you didn't play
good at all that one was so
close as durant who had a great fourth
quarter but
unable to get that game-tying shot
[Applause]
giannis athena football and chris
middleton 68
of the bucks 86 points and again led by
middleton
well just a fantastic bounce-back game
and the series is now two games to one
in favor of the nets
as the [ __ ] right back in it